even if you don't know Zack Snyder by
name you are most likely familiar with
his work in a short period of time
Snyder has carved out a nice within the
comic book superhero film universe
through his stunning effects and a very
unique visual style that includes
dynamic compositions and highly
saturated colors that enhance his
storytelling Snyder burst onto the scene
with his feature directorial debut
2004's Dawn of the Dead armed with a
handful of Clio awards for his work in
advertising
Zack was tasked with tackling the remake
of the classic George a Romero's zombie
film Snyder had a hefty budget and put
it to good use
employing some big-budget special
effects something that would become a
stylistic Snyder hallmark the film was
well received and put the newbie
director on the map enough to get his
next project Greenland
although 2006 is 300 was only Snyder's
second film it would both introduce and
define what would become his signature
visual style with heavy influences from
Frank Miller's graphic novel and
stunning slow motion effects Snyder used
his visuals to underscore the unfolding
violence as well as the tone of the film
300 also proved to be the first of many
times in his films that Snyder explored
the theme of the tragic nature of
heroism that coupled with his newfound
reputation for high body counts and
widespread destruction the young
director was beginning to make his mark
on fellow filmmakers Snyder's next
project would be his first foray into
the costume superhero genre Watchmen was
another hot graphic novel Studios had
been looking to adapt to the screen the
property was entrusted to the young
director who continued to explore and
refine his stylistic slow motion effects
driven visuals not to mention his rising
body count
although the end result got mixed
reviews the film showed the evolution of
how Zack would treat costumed characters
in movies to come with sucker punch
Snyder not only continued to play with
visual storytelling but he also played
with music in the form of stylized
montages set to popular songs a callback
to his days directing for the likes of
Morrissey and soul asylum
most recently Snyder has been tasked
with bringing the DC Comics universe
from comic book pages to the silver
screen in a genre dominated by the
Marvel Universe Snyder hopes that his
take on the genre will prove successful
with audiences
so far he's off to a flying start with
his take on the Superman mythology in
2013's Man of Steel which will be
followed up by the hotly anticipated
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
if early buzz holds true Snyder's unique
style should be firmly cemented in the
superhero action genre which is no easy
feat considering the recent surge in
this franchise driven genre that is
constantly trying to raise the level of
action and intensity with each new movie
release with the body of work he has
created so far along with the continued
evolution of his style
Zack Snyder is definitely an influence
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]